استدعاء ترامب للمحكمه عنوان العالم الاول
لنجومه الرئيس السابق وممثله افلام اباحيه
ومحامي سابق ومحامي حالي واخرين وتساؤلات
كثيره عن القادم هل سيسجن ترامب واللي
صاير هذا كله هل هو انتصار للديمقراطيه ام
انهيار لها نحاول الوصول لاجابه في
تفاعلكم اليوم اهلا بكم
[موسيقى]
في رمضان تفاعلكم مركز معكم مشاهدينا على
الدراما والمسلسلات لكن اليوم اسمحوا لنا
نعمل استثناء فبعيدا عن المسلسلات في فيلم
شغال الان ما فينا نتجاهله ابدا وفيلم
ينفع نسميه فيلم الموسم نحن بنتكلم طبعا
عن الموضوع الابرز والاول على مختلف
الشاشات والعناوين اليوم استدعاء الرئيس
الامريكي السابق دونالد ترامب الى المحكمه
اليوم لتوجيه التهم رسميا في قضيه شاغل
العالم كله خلينا نبدا حلقتنا اليوم مثل
الرئيس الامريكي السابق دونالد ترامب امام
محكمه منهات في نيويورك لابلاغه رسميا
بتوجيه تهم جنائيه ضد في قضيه بدات باخبار
انه دفع اموال لممثله افلام اباحيه لشراء
صمتها عن علاقه سابقه جمعتهم الممثله اللي
بنتكلم عنها هي ستورميدان يلز واسمها
الحقيقي ستيفاني كليفورد في 2006 يعني قبل
سنوات من ترشحه للرئاسه كان في اشاعات عن
علاقه بين ترامب وبينها وفي طلعت اخبار عن
حوار مرتقب عن العلاقه اجرى دستومي مع او
اجره في 2011 تحديدا مع احدى المجلات لكن
لاحقا ما انتشر الحوار او مد نشر الحوار
وقال الناس انه السبب انه محامي ترامب
السابق اللي هو مايكل هدد بمقاداتها راحت
السنين وبعد سنوات في 2018 فجرت صحيفه
وولس المفاجاه عن العلاقه وقالت انه يا
جماعه قبل الانتخابات الرئاسيه في 2016
ترامب دفع 130 الف دولار للممثله هذه
علشان ما تفشي سر العلاقه بينهم ووقتها في
2016 كان بالضبط قبل الانتخابات فتره ممكن
يبغى فضائح وتشويش يعني وقيل او قبل انه
محامي كون يدفع لها 130 الف دولار ولاحقا
اعترف محامي ترامب السابق مع الكوبون بدفع
المبلغ من ماله الخاص التوجيه من ترامب
لاحقا ترامب رجع الفلوس لكون وكتبها في
سجلات الماليه انها اتعاب قضائيه وهنا
المشكله ومربط الفرس في هذه القضيه الفلوس
هذه مو اتعاب محاماه بعد ما اعترفوا باللي
صار طلعت فيه مقابله مع برنامج 6 منت وروه
القصه كامله وكشفت تفاصيل صادمه وقالت
انها تعرفت على ترامب في نادي الجولف في
2006 ودعاها للعشاء في غرفته بالفندق
وبتقول انه صارت بينهم علاقه جنسيه وانا
تعرضت للتهديد من بدايات خروج القضيه
للاعلام وانها فكرت في 2011 انها تبيع
القضيه لما جل مقابل 15 الف دولار لكن في
رجل مجهول هددها بابنتها وعائلتها وهدد
كمان بمقاضاه المجله وانه محامي ترامب
اجبرها في 2016 على توقيع اتفاقيه صمت
وانه في حال انتهاكها حتدفع غرامه ضخمه
واعطاها 130 الف دولار علشان تسكت وطبعا
كل هذه الروايات مشاهدينا ترامب بين فيها
وبيقول انها مو صحيحه وانه هو ما ارتكب اي
مخالفه للقوانين وانه اصلا من 2018 اكون
ما عاد محامين طيب بالعوده للحاضر الان
هذه القصه مع شراء صمته كانت او صمته كانت
مفتاح القضيه الحاليه ضده واللي فيها
اتهامات بدفع رشوه لسيده اخرى وايضا
انتهاك قوانين الحملات الانتخابيه كعاده
ترامب توجه لمنصته
لمؤخرا هي ميلاده في كل شيء بيصير معه ومن
قبل ما يوصل نيويورك كان بدا يكتب بوستات
واحد ورا الثاني فكتب قبل ما يغادر بوست
قال فيه انه هو راح يسافر الاثنين الى
نيويورك وقال انه صدقوا او لا تصدقوا راح
اروح الى قاعه المحكمه وقال انه مو مفترض
تكون امريكا بهذا الحال ومن بعد
جديد قال فيه انه مدعي عام
سرب لائحه الاتهام هذه وهذا غير قانوني
ولازم الان المدعي العام نفسه توجه لتهم
ورجع اضاف في بوست ثاني انه المدعي العام
بنفسه اتسرب 33 نقطه من لائحه الاتهام
وقال هذه فوضى ولازم المدعي العام يستقيل
ومن بعدها صعد لهجته ضد برافو وصفوه
بالمجنون اليساري الراديكالي وقال انه
لازم يستقيل فورا واما اخر بوست او اخر
بوست كان نشر وترمت من ساعات فطالب في
بنقل مكان المحاكمه من مكانها الحالي الى
او اللي هي تعتبر مكانها الحالي هي منطقه
1% فيها بس جمهوريين طلب بنقل المحاكمه
الى جزيره ستاتن ايلاند في نيويورك ايضا
لانها موقع عادل وامن جدا للمحاكمه حسب
ترامب طيب كل اللي ذكرته سابقا ملخص بسيط
والله
للقصه تعالوا الان نتكلم سوا في اللي صار
اليوم تحديدا ترامب الموجود في نيويورك
توجه لي المحكمه في منهاجا طلع من ترامبور
وسط استنفار امني مشدد ووصل الى المحكمه
وكان في المئات من انصاره متجمعين في
المكان ورافعين شعارات بتدعموا وبتدعم
ترشحه الانتخابات عشرين اربعه وعشرين وتم
النقل على لسان ترامب وهو داخل للمحكمه
قوله
سيعتقلونني لا اصدق ذلك
[موسيقى]
ومن بعد ما دخلت المحكمه توالت الاخبار
بالنسبه للاجراءات اللي صارت داخلها
ابتداء من اخذ بصمات بصماته مثل اي متهم
اخر مرورا بالقيود او الكلبشات اللي الناس
كانت مستنيه تشوف هل راح يلبسها ترامب او
لا الناس كمان كانت مستنيه تشوف وتسمع هل
او راح يتصور ترامب سوره المتهمين الشهيره
بالمقشاط المدعي العام كان طلع واعلن انه
ما راح يطلب من ترامب انه يتصورها ولكن
ترامب تفاجا الجميع وطالب بانه يصوروها او
يصوروها لكن عموما في النهايه ما تصورها
طبعا المقشط اللي احنا بنقول عنها اللي هو
يكون واقف الشخص وماسك كده يعني رقم او
انه الرقم القضيه حقته طيب هو فقد اخذت
ودخل قاعه المحكمه ومثل امام القاضي وتليت
عليه اللائحه بالتهم الموجهه ضده واللي رد
عليها بنفيها جميعا طبعها طبعا التهم هي
34 على فكره ومن ضمنها دفع رشاوي وتزوير
التجاريه وكمان تامر وامامكم على الشاشه
الان الوثيقه الرسميه للتهمم الموجهه ضده
طبعا ترامب طبعا نفا كل الاتهامات هذه ومن
بعدها اخلي سبيل وبدون شروط وغادر المحكمه
الى مطار لاغوارديا للعوده الى فلوريدا
واللي راح يتوجه منها بكلمه لانصاره خلال
ساعات كلمه طبعا مرتقبه من قبل الاكثيرين
معنى من نيويورك مديره مكتب العربيه في
واشنطن ناديه البلبيسي اهلا فيك معنا يا
ناديه يوم حافل صراحه بالاحداث كيف كانت
رده الفعل والمشهد وراك عند المحكمه وما
الى ذلك بعد خصوصا بعد حديث المدعي العام
وخروج التهم للعلن
مساء الخير ساره اول شيء كنت استمع في
الواقع للسرد كان شيق جدا ودقيق جدا بكل
ما ذكرتيه حتى الان وطبعا عنوانكم رائع يا
ناديه وكل مدن بريء حتى اكيد اكيد اكيد
عنوان هذا الفيلم هو المذنب وكل مذنب
بريئه حتى تثبت اذانتو طبعا الرئيس هذه
النهايه الفن لا نعرف اذا كانت ستكون
سعيده بالكامل اي
القاضي سيغلق هذه القضيه لانه الان بدانا
بدانا نسمع ردود الافعال وفي الواقع لم
يكن هناك مفاجات يعني كان هناك تشويق لكن
لم يكن هناك مفاجات بانه كنا نعرف بان
رئيس اتهم بدفع هذه الاموال 130 الف دولار
كنا نعرف عن المراه الاخرى ايضا وهي كارين
مكدودو لكن ايضا ربما هذا الشخص الاخير
العام الذي كان في برجه وحاول ان يكسب
ايضا لكن كل هذا في اطار الحمله
الانتخابيه وتزوير بعض الوثائق الى اخره
هناك شعور ربما بخيبه الامل من قبل بعض
الاشخاص الذين كانوا يريدون بالفعل ان
يكون هناك دليل اقوى ضد الرئيس ترامب وان
يتم ادانته طبعا هو ذهب الى جوا سنرى طبعا
لانه هو سيد اقتناص الفرص هو يحول كل
الازمات الى فرص والى
مصلحته يعني سواء كانت المصلحه الانتخابيه
بجمع الاموال او بحشد مؤيديه وراينا قبل
قليل كل ردود الافعال من الجمهورين
بالتحديد وخصوصا من منتقدين مثل سنه
غير مؤهل لان يكون رئيس الولايات المتحده
ويختلف معهم في كل النواحي وخصوصا موضوع
اخلاقي لانه هو رجل محافظ يقيم
المبادئ الاسريه وغيرها اتحدث
على ترامب ومن هنا يقول
يعني يفوز بالرئاسه لا اعرف يعني لن اراهن
على فوزه بالرئاسه لكن استطيع ان اقول
بانه قد يفوز بترشح الحزب الجمهوري هناك
انتخابات تمهيديه وهناك شخص ينافس ترامب
وهو حاكم
اكثر حظا يعني لا نتحدث
السابق ولا غيرها من الاسماء حتى لكن
بالفعل هناك تاييد للترامب ب 90% واكثر في
داخل حزب الجمهوري لكن بالنسبه للمستقلين
وبالنسبه للمشككين وبالنسبه للمعارضين
لترامب كل سجله بما فيه لا اعتقد بانه
كافيه لاقناعهم بالتصويت له في الانتخابات
الرئاسيه طيب
ناديه كيف كانت الاوضاع الامنيه يعني كان
قبل من ايام وهي نيويورك بتستعد امنيا
الله
يبدو صار عندك شيء
بالضبط هذا موكب
الان يمر ربما هو تمام لا مش ترامب لا
المدعي العامه خلص راح
بس
مدعي العام ممكن ايه بس كان في قبل اسابيع
من اسبوع صاروا بيستعدوا وبتكلموا عن
الاستعدادات الامنيه هل صارت اي مشاكل او
اي شيء من هذا القبيل
لا كل الاجراءات الامنيه كانت احترازيه
بالدرجه الاولى اولا حتى لا نرى سيناريو
يتكرر في نيويورك كما حدث في واشنطن مع
انه المشابهه والمقاربه مختلفه تماما في
ذلك الوقت كان هناك عشرات الالاف من
مؤيدين رئيس ترامب ولا اذكر كنت امام مبنى
الكابيتال في ذلك اليوم على اساس انها
مظاهرات سلميه لكنها تحولت الى عنيفه
اقتحام للمبنى الذي هزه الديمقراطيه
الامريكيه والدخول الى مكتب خمس اشخاص
يعني في النهايه لكن هنا 30 الف عنصر من
الشرطه ومن الاف بي اي ومن الحرس الوطني
لا احد يستطيع ان يتحرك بعض المشدات
الكلاميه البسيطه بين اتباع ترامب الذين
يلاحظوها او الذين تظاهروا ضده ببعض
الشعارات لكن لم نرى وجود كبير لمناصري
الرئيس والقضيه مختلفه يعني الاولى كانت
يعني التشكيت في انتخابات ويعني الامل
بعوده ترامكا رئيس الول المتحده في ذلك
الوقت بتحدي النتائج ونتحدث الان عن اتهام
لدفع الممثله اباحيه نعم طيب ناديه نحن
بنشكرك على هذه المداخله معنا واطلانا على
الاوضاع عندكم طبعا انا عارفه انه يومك
طويل وحيستمر هذا اليوم طويل فيعطيك
العافيه كل انت وكل فريق العربيه طبعا في
امريكا شكرا لك كانت معنا من نيويورك
مديره مكتب العربيه في واشنطن ناديه
البلبيسي
اهلا من جديد ترمت بواجه 34 تهمه شفنا من
قليل لائحه فيها
هذه الاتهامات منها اتهامات برشاوي
الاثنين
خارج اطار الزواج وفي اتهامات بمخالفه
قانون الانتخابات وغيرها وغيرهم اسئله
كثير الان مطروحه عن ابطال القصه مثل ما
سبق وسميناهم في بدايه الحلقه في ترامب
ومعروف طبعا
النجمه الابرز ومحركه الاتهامات لكن في
ايضا القانونيين في هذه القصه فعندنا
محاميين ترامب واخرهم اللي اضافوا
في اللحظه
المحامي هو مدعي عام السابق وبيتمتع بسمعه
جيده كمحامي للدفاع و مدافع عدواني كما
نقيل انه تم ترشيحه من قبل احد كبار
مستشاري ترامب اللي قال انه بل كان الخيار
الصحيحي لتمثيل الرئيس
الجنائيه الموجهه ضده وكده انضم بلانش الى
كل من
اللي كانوا بيمثلوا ترامب من بدايه
الاتهامات الى اليوم اما القاضي لتحول
لنجم بسبب هذه القضيه او اللي مثل امامه
ترامب فهو القاضي اخوان مرجان قاضي
المحكمه العليا في نيويورك بالانابه التي
تم وصفه بانه محنك وصارم وعادل في نفس
الوقت وفي وهو نفسه حكم سابقا بالسجن
المدير المالي لمؤسسه ترامب وتراس كمان
محاكمه الاحتيال الضريبي للمؤسسه واشرف
على قضيه الاحتيال الجنائي لمستشار ترامب
السابق ستيف بانون ويمكن عشان كذا قال انه
هذا القاضي بيكرهه نجم اخر من نجوم القضيه
هو المدعي العام
طلع بمؤتمر صحفي من اقل من ساعه وقال
وجهنا 34 اتهاما لترامب لمحاوله اخفاء
اخرى وقال انه ما في دوافع سياسيه حول
قضيه ترامب وانه نفذ تحقيق شامل بشانها
وقال كمان انه تبع سلوك اجرامي خطير
وانتهى قوانين تمويل الحملات الانتخابيه
ودفع اموال رشاوي عبر شركات وهميه وقدم
تصريحات زائفه لتغطيه جرائم مرتبطه
بانتخابات 2016 ودفع اموال لتزوير سجلاته
التاريخ او التجاريه طيب قبل المدعي العام
محامين ترامب كانوا وبعد مغادرته مبنى
المحكمه اتكلموا مع الاعلام وقالوا انه
اتهام وكلهم الرئيس السابق يؤكد ان سياده
القانون ماتت في هذه البلاد وانه ما في اي
مؤشرات على ارتكاب الرئيس السابق لاي
جريمه فيدراليه وقالوا كمان انه اتهامه
امر محبط وحزين
وحقيقه الاسئله الان كثيره جدا ايش اللي
راح يصير هل راح يسجن ترامب واذا انسجن رح
يترجح من السجن للرئاسه وهل في حال اذا
انتم راح يتم منعه من الترشح للرئاسه
اسئله كثيره والكل بيبحث عن اجابات لانه
في النهايه ترامب اول رئيس امريكي بيتم
توجيه تهم جنائيه له طيب احنا حينضم الينا
من عمان المحامي المزاول في نيويورك محمد
تيسير النعيمي اهلا فيك معانا وخلينا
نبتدي اول شيء من التهم الموجه نحن بنتكلم
عن 34 تهمه بس يعني ما احنا عارفين ايش
الفرق بانه هي جنائيه بس برجعوا بعدين
قالوا انه لا هي جنح وتهم بسيطه اذا تقدر
تشرح لنا ايش الفرق قالوا ايه حتى وصفوها
ويسعد مساكي ورمضان كريم نعم يعني اسند
اليوم لرئيس الولايات المتحده الامريكيه
السابق دونالد ترامب 34 تهمه جنائيه وليست
جنحه تتعلق بتقديم معلومات غير صحيحه
لبيانات الماليه المتعلقه لترامب
مؤسسه ترامب السبب الرئيسي ليش هذه ما تم
اسنادها كجنحه وتم اسنادها كجنايه لانه
ينص القانون في حال كان الفعل المرتكب
متبوع بينيه جرميه متعلقه باخفاء واقعه
جرميه اخرى او متعلقه بجريمه جرميه اخرى
يتم رفع هذه التهمه الى درجه الجنايه وهذا
ما تم ما تم ما تم اليوم في المحكمه يعني
ارتفع الموضوع الى جنايه لانه شايفين انه
في جرم كان
يعني الهدف كان
جرم معين او خلينا نقول تحقيق ما تم تقديم
هذه المعلومات المغلوطه وفقط ولكن هذه
المعلومات المغلوطه تتعلق بواقعه اخرى قد
تكون غير قانونيه او متعلقه بفعل جرمي
فلما يكون عندي
الحالتين هذول مع بعض يتم رفع هذه التورمه
التهمه الى جنايه اوكي وهذا ما يزعموه
الادعاء العام في لائحه الاتهام خليني بس
بدي امشي معك شويه في تفاصيل اللي صار
داخل المحكمه بس عشان نفهم طبعا كان في
موضوع انه هو توجيه التهم كان في قصه انه
اخذوا بصمات وكان في قصه انه يحطوا له
كلبشات او ما يحطوا له كلبشات هذا لم يحدث
ما حطوا له كلبشات كان في قصه المج شوط هم
قالوا ما حياخدوها طالب فيها ترامب ثم هما
رفضوا انه ياخذوا المقشط هذه التفاصيل انه
تصير او ما تصير تكلبش او ما يتكلبش هذه
اجباريه ولا بالاتفاق بتصير
نعم ستي هي يعني بالمجمل الاجباريه ويمكن
ان تصير في حالتين اما تصير في المركز
الامني او ممكن تصير في حال ادخال المتهم
عليه الى المشتكى عليه الى المحكمه في
العاده كل ما زادت حده كل ما زادت درجه
التهمه المسنده تكون الاجراءات مقيده اكثر
فيكون المشتكى عليه بيكون مكلبش لما يفوت
لازم اخذ صورته التعريفيه ولازم اخذ ولازم
اخذ بصماته الهدف من الصوره التعريفيه هي
للتعرف على المشتكي عليه فاحد محامين
ترامب اثار نقطه امام القاضي ورقيا لما
قدم هذا الطلب انه من اكثر الاشخاص
المعروفين في هذا العالم فما في حاجه اصلا
لهذه الصوره التعريفيه ولكن هذا اجراء
روتيني بيدخل الشخص المحكمه يتم ايداعه
الى مكتب هذا المكتب ياخذ بصماته ياخذ
صورته بكون مكتوب عليها رقم القضيه
الحقيقيه ورقم القضيه اللي بلشت الان
ثم
خليني كمان بدي اتكلم معك على موضوع
الكفاله يعني هو ترامب غادر مقر المحكمه
الجنائيه من دون ان تفرض عليه اي شروط او
مراقبه قضائيه بس هل عاده بيكون المفروض
يكون في كفاله هل بيكون في منع من السفر
مثلا في هذه الحاله ولا زي ما قلت هو
شخصيه يعني مشهوره واعتباريه يعني
يا سيدتي هذا هو الاصل ان يتم اطلاق سراح
المشتكي عليه بدون كفاله الا اذا كان
هنالك ظروف او اشي
تتولد ضد القاضي انه ممكن هذا الشخص ما
يمثل في المحاكمه الثانيه او ممكن انه
يهرب خارج البلاد وكل ما زادت حده التهمه
كل ما كانت الكفاله ستكون مشروطه القاضي
ثلاث ثلاث خيارات امامه اطلاق فراحوا بدون
كفاله ما حدث اليوم اطلاق سراح المتهم
عليه مع كفاله او ايداع المتهم عليه الى
السجن هذه في حال العقوبات التي تمتد الى
القاتل والعقبات
القويه ايوه طيب وموضوع السفر ولكن كونه
ولكن كونه ترامب هذه اول جنايه يتم
اسنادها اليه وما عنده اسبقيات جرميه
كثيره فارت القاضي انه اطلاق سراحه بدون
بدون كفاله موضوع السفر نفس المعايير
والمحددات بتطبق على السفر في حال كان عند
القاضي انه ممكن المشتكي عليه انه يسافر
او ممكن انه يفر من هذه البلد هيحط عليه
منع سفر انا تحليلي لربما سيكون هنالك منع
سفر ولكن هذا سيعتمد على كيف بتطور القضيه
يعني هاي من القرارات المستعجله قد يمكن
انه القاضي يصدرها في بدايه المحكمه ويمكن
ان تصدر في وقت لاحق كيف تطور القضيه ممكن
ينزل قرارات مستعجله اخرى طيب خليني اقول
لك بس سريعا طلب
رئيس الامريكي السابق دونالد ترامب تغيير
مكان
المحاكمه لانه شايف انه مكان المحاكمه
الحالي غير محايد بالنسبه له هل تتوقع
ممكن يصير هذا الشيء او يلبى طلبه
لا اتوقع لانه هنالك محددات قانونيه للطعن
في ولايه المحكمه المكانيه زي ما هم
بطعنوا على الفانيو ولكن هو ثابت الولايه
على ترامب نفسه والولايه على الفعل الجرمي
ثابته الى
والمحكمه اللي في منهات اللي هي المحكمه
المختصه بمثل هذه البيانات التجاريه
الادعاء اللي قدموه محاميه ترامبو ترامب
نفسه انه هاي المحكمه الليبراليه ومتحيزه
للديمقراطيين وكامل الكادر فيها يمين
للديمقراطيين لا اتوقع ان يرتقي الى يرتقي
الى سبب قانوني يمكن ان ينقل منه المحكمه
الى موقع اخر وهما
طالبوا ان تنت المحكمه الى مقاطعه وهي احد
خمس مقاطعات ولايه نيويورك طيب
خلينا نتكلم عن الاحتمالات اللي ممكن تصير
هل ممكن ان يسجن
يعني في سابقه اليوم ولكن مو ملاقيين
عليها معلومات كفايه وهي انه غير الجنايات
التي تم اسنادهم الى ترامب تم اسناد طبعا
جنايه التامر وهذه لانها متعلقه بالجنايه
بولايه نيويورك يمكن ان تكون مده الحبس
اكثر من الجنايه نفسها
كون انه ترامب الان على الجنايات الاربعه
وثلاثين في حال اذا انتو بال 34 اتوقع نعم
سيكون مصيره هو هو سجن وفي حال اذانته
بالتامر فيكون مصيره
السجن ولكن ذلك يعتمد على هل سيتمكن ادعاء
العام من اثبات هذه التهم وهل سيتمكن
امر التامر هي اكبر تهمه بيواجهها
يعني هي طبعا اكبر من هاي اكبر من جنايه
الادلاء بمعلومات غير دقيقه
فهمت التامر وهي تهمه التامر استنبطوها من
واقع القصص الثلاثه اللي صرتيها بمقدمتك
الدفعه 150 الف لاحد السيدات
اللي هم بيقدموها طيب الان افتراضا القضيه
مثلا ممكن مشهد سنوات او ممكن مشهد شهور
طويله واحنا داخلين على انتخابات مقبله هل
ممكن ان يترشح وسط هذه القضيه وهي دايره
هل ممكن يترشح اذا كان في السجن
اذا كان في السجن طبعا لا يمكن ان يترشح
لانه يمارس حقوق المدنيه منها حق الترشح
لرئاسه الجمهوريه بعد خروج من السجن ولكن
في حال ادانته واستبدال هذه الادانه
بغرامه او او عدم ادانته او عدم
حبسه فقط الاكتفاء بالغرامه يمكن الترشح
يعني من الغريب انه القانون الامريكي
والدستور الامريكي ما في عنده اي محددات
على حق الترشح كرئيس للولايات المتحده
الامريكيه هناك شرطين لازم يتم المترشح
عمر 35 او عمر خمس او المترشحه عمر 35 سنه
ولازم ان يكون مولود في الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه او اي في منطقه تحت سيطرتها اذا
قارناها بحق التصويت
سنجد انه هناك محددات اكثر على حق التصويت
ففي بعض الولايات المتحده الامريكيه تفقد
حقق للتصويت في حال ادانتك بجنايه اذا
لاحظنا ب 2016 حاكم ولايه تكساس السابق
كان احد المنافسين يا دونالد ترامبو كان
مداهم بجنايه ساعه استعمال السلطه في كثير
محاميين وقانونيين جالسين انه بالقضيه
بيقولوا انه هذه القضيه مركبه ما لها اساس
تجميع تهم وما الى ذلك هل بتتفق مع هذا
بعد اطلاعك على تفاصيل القضيه ولا لا
بتعتقد ان لا قضيه جديه وهم عندهم يعني
مكملينها
في اكثر من تهم بالتهم المتعلقه بالتامل
وانه هو هدد نزاهه الانتخابات الامريكيه
اتوقع هاي يعني هاي التهم الى سند
القانوني ولكن تهم انه هو ادرك معلومات
خاطئه اتوقع انها هي صحيحه
ويعني وثابته وثابته قانونيه ولكن لربما
هناك دوافع سياسيه بتحريكها لانه اذا نيجي
نراجع كامل السجلات التجاريه اللي خاضعه
على نيويورك على ولايه محاكم نيويورك
حنلاقي هنلاقي مثل هاي المخالفات بشكل
يومي
شكرا لك يعني
استفدنا كثير من المعلومات اللي اعطتنا
اياها اليوم كان معنا من عمان المحامي
المزاول في نيويورك محمد تيسير النعيمي
شكرا لك
[موسيقى]
العالم كله حرفيا اليوم ما له عنوان او
سيره الا ترامب واخبار ترامب واستدعاءه
ومحاكمته والموضوع بدا فعليا من امس من
وقت رحلته مع عدد من مساعديه ومستشاري في
فلوريدا مقر اقامته الى مطار لجوع في
نيويورك مكان المحاكمه على متن طائرته
الخاصه الطائره اللي اطلق عليها اسم
ترامبوش 1 اسوه يعني
الطائره الرئاسيه المخصصه للرئيس الامريكي
الرحله هذه كانت الاكثر تتبعا في جميع
انحاء العالم وفقا لفلايت رادار وشاهد
التغطيات مباشره من اغلب القنوات الاجنبيه
والعربيه اللي تابعتها لحظه بلحظه على مدى
ساعتين ونص وتم استقباله في مطار لجوه
عيديه من قبل الخدمه السريه الخاصه فيه
وتم ايصاله الى برج ترامب حيث يقيم وحيث
كان يقيم ايام ما كانت مقر اقامته في
نيويورك تحت حراسه امنيه مشدده
انا
طيب مشاهدينا الان خلينا ننقلكم الى صور
مباشره من مطار بيتش حيث طبعا هناك لسه في
انتظار طائره الرئيس الامريكي السابق
دونالد ترامب انها تهبط اللي هي الطائره
اللي قلنا لكم انه اسمها
طبعا الطائره ما زال امامها ساعه تقريبا
الى الوصول ولكن كل شاشات العالم
بتراقب هذه اللحظه وفي كثير شاشات جلسه
بتنقل هذا المشهد لايف فقط في انتظار لحظه
وصول
الطائره ونزول ترامب منها وطبعا
ذهاب الى مقر اقامته في بالم بيت اللي هو
مارلاجو حيث متم المتوقع ان يلقي كلمه
مهمه جدا امام انصاره
طبعا الاهتمام هذا انعكس من شاشات
التلفزيون للمنصات في ترند اول حول العالم
وبمختلف اللغات والناس بتتابع وبتترقب
وبتحاول تفهم ايش اللي راح يصير وبتبحث عن
معلومات واخبار تقدر من خلالها تفهم
القضيه او ايش اللي بيواجه ترامب على جوجل
شوفوا امامكم الزياده في البحث عن اسم
ترامب خلال يوم واحد بس هذا غير الزياره
بالالاف في وزياده بالالاف عفوا في المئه
في نسب البحث عن كل ما يتعلق في المحاكمه
مواضيع الاعتقال والمحاكمه في المراتب
الاولى في البحث على جوجل وزاد البحث
عليها
180% اما الاسئله على جوجل فكل ما يخص
التهم ضده واعتقاله واستدعائه زاد البحث
عنه بالالاف في المئه والمئات في المئه
الموضوع طبعا مفهوم ومو غريب يعني رئيس
امريكي سابق توجه لوجههم جنائيه يعني هذا
الموضوع غير مسبوق ومهم وحتى اي
بيروح للمحكمه وبيسلم نفسه وبتطلع العواجل
انه هو الان قيد الاعتقال وتفاصيل كلبشات
وكذا صادم جدا هل هذا فعلا انتصار
للديمقراطيه ولا يعني تحطيم لرمز كبير في
امريكا
طبعا يعني المنظر كما تفضلت صادم جدا لبعض
الناس ومريح جدا للبعض الاخر اذا نظرنا
الى الديمقراطيه طبعا اكبر رئيس في بلد
يعني
امبراطوريه مثل الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه يراسها رئيس وهو خرج من السلطه
والان يخضع للقانون مثله مثل اي انسان
عادي هذا انتصار كبير لمبدا الديمقراطيه
وهو المساواه امام القانون اي لا فرق بين
كبير او صغير لكن اين الاشكاليه تكمن
الاشكاليه ان مؤسسه القانون هي الان محل
شك ان هناك قسم كبير من الامريكيين يرون
ان القضاء يستخدم كاداه سياسيه للنيل من
رئيس ترامب وهذا بحد ذاته يطعن في
الديمقراطيه وبهذا الحال نجد ان هناك
انقسام كبير في البلد والمفروض من
الديمقراطيه ان تمنع هذا الانقسام وان
تجعل الناس يتفقوا على مشترك واحد لكنها
كما يبدو في الولايات المتحده الامريكيه
لا يتفق على مشترك واحد يتفقوا على
الابتعاد عن بعضهم وربما يؤدي الى صدام
يعني هناك خلاف كبير قد ينتهي الى الشارع
لذلك الديمقراطيه في امريكا الان بقدر من
اراها جميله الا انها مريضه بنفس الوقت
وهذا المرض اذا لم يسارع يعني الى حله في
الانتخابات القادمه من قبل الناس يعني اذا
لم ينجح ترامب تحل القضيه اما اذا نجح
الرئيس الامريكي ترامب فان الديمقراطيه
طبعا كلها ستكون يعني محل تساؤل كبير بس
حتى اذا يعني يعني انت بتقول اذا ما نجح
ترامب انه يعني حيتحسن الموضوع طب ما الان
اترمت ما هو مترشح وبايض هو الديمقراطيين
في الحكم والانقسام كبير جدا يعني وملاحقه
ترمط مستمره علشان ما يدخل في الانتخابات
القادمه او هكذا يعني بيقولوا المدافعين
عنه يعني
طبعا يعني المشكله ترامب ليس قوي فقط لانه
ترامب او يتكلم ماذا يريد هو قوي لان هناك
يعني في نوع من الانقسام داخل المجتمع
الامريكي قبل ترامب وسيبقى بعد ترامب لكن
ترامب هو المحرك الماده الكيماويه التي
تجعله يتفجر ما هو هذا الانقسام ان هناك
في المجتمع الامريكي شرائح من البيض
وبالتحديد من الكنيسه
يعتقدون انهم في خطر اي انهم ليسوا اصحاب
البلد وهناك ايضا شرائح اخرى تعتبر ان
هناك طبقه من المتنفزين الماليين مع الناس
في السلطه يتحكمون بمصير الناس ويرون ان
كل ذلك لا يصح ديمقراطيا والترامب دخوله
على على الخط استطاع ان يستغل هذه الظاهره
بالذات شريحه الناس المتزمرين من رجال
المال والاعمال وغيره اما الكنيسه فرات
فيه يعني كما يقولون رجال الكنيسه خلاصا
انها امام خيارين اما ان ترى رجلا شريفا
وطيبا تستطيع ان تدعمه ويصل الى الرئاسه
ويحقق لها مطالبها مثل منع الاجهاض وقديم
هي وغيرها التي تعرضها الكنيسه او انها
تعتمد على ترامب لان له شعبيه مع اعتقادها
انه فاسد لكن ترى فيه مثل فيروس يعني
الامبراطور الفارسي الذي انقذ اليهود
بمعنى اخر الكنيسه تستغل ترامب للوصول الى
الاهدافها عبره هذه القضايا يعني نعم نعم
مقابل ذلك هناك الليبراليين الذين يعني
يرون ان كل هذه الامور لا يمكن القبول بها
وانه يجب ان تعطى للانسان الحريه المطلقه
وكذلك الليبراليه الماليه الشركات كل هذا
ادى الى تصادم في المجتمع الامريكي هو
الماده الكيماويه المفجره له طيب يعني
دكتور احمد خلينا نخرج حتى من خارج امريكا
العالم جالس بيتابع المشهد بالنسبه للعالم
اول شيء الكلام اللي جالس بيطلع انه في
تشكيك في القضاء الامريكي اللي دايما بيتم
تصويره بالنزاهه والمثاليه واتضح للناس
انه لا في ميول ديمقراطيه في ميول جمهوريه
وهكذا ثاني شيء منصب رئيس امريكا بمعزل
مين اللي في المنصب هذا المنصب له فخامه
يعني واهميته لما نشوف المشهد هذا الان
نحن من برا هذا ما كله بيهز كثير قيم مهمه
هم اخذتهم صينيين يصنعوها
طبعا يعني هناك نموذجان النموذج الصيني
والنموذج الامريكي النموذج الصيني يقوم
على قضيه انه لا يهم لون البطه كان سوداء
او بيضاء المهم ان البطه تبيض يعني النظام
الصيني يقوم على مبدا ان هناك حاكم قوي
يدير البلاد يؤمن للناس كل ما تحتاجه من
طبابه واكل وصناعه وان الحريه تعطى بقدر
معين لان اطلاقها بالكامل يكون ضرب
المجتمع هذا نموذج حتى الان في الصين قائم
واستطاعت الصين ان تحقق انجازات كبرى
النموذج الثاني هو في الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه والدول الديمقراطيه وهي الحريه
الشخصيه والمساواه وان الناس لهم الحق ان
يقرروا من ينتخبوا وان يعارضوه وان
يختلفوا على كل شيء لكن بالنهايه يخضع الى
القانون القانون هنا كما ذكرنا هنا
المشكله الان ان هناك تشكيك فيه لكن
التشكيك فيه بدا حتى مع عهد ترامب لانه هو
الذي يعني ملا المحكمه العليا بمؤيدين له
يعني رجال قانون معروفون بارائهم وبالتالي
اصبح القضاء مسيسا في امريكا على مستوى
المحكمه العليا اما على مستوى المحاكم
الدنيا فاعتقد ان الاتهامات الموجهه
لترامبيه اهتمامات واقعيه امر حدث ويحاكم
على اساسها لذلك اعتقد ان القضيه معقده
جدا والديمقراطيه لها محاسن كثيره ولها
مساوئ كثيره لكن كما قال افلاطون انها في
النهايه ستكون ديمقراطيه الرعاع والهمش
بمعنى او هم الذين يسيطرون في النهايه هل
سيحدث ذلك سنرى في الانتخابات القادمه هل
سيحسم الامريكيون رايهم وينتخبون ترامب
وتبدا مرحله جديده تشبه المرحله الصينيه
او انهم لا ينتخبون ونعود الى الديمقراطيه
القديمه بعد القرون دي كلها كلام ولا زال
صحيح طيب دكتور احمد بس في موضوع حابه
اسمع تعليقك علاء سريعا جدا في خلال مثول
ترامب امام المحكمه كان في مؤتمر صحفي
لبايدن عن الذكاء الاصطناعي رفض الاجابه
عن اسئله بتتعلق بترمب وكان في مؤتمر صحفي
اخر للمتحدثه باسم البيت الابيض وكان لها
تصريح احب نسمعه وتعلق عليه سريعا بعد ما
نسمعه اتفضل
تفضل دكتور احمد ايش رايك طبعا يعني شيء
معروف جدا يعني الرئيس الامريكي لا يريد
ان يدخل في معمعك هذه وبالتالي اي كلمه
يتفوه بها ستحسب ضده خاصه من الفريق
المؤيد الرئيس ترامب لذلك هو حاول تجنب
الموضوع وتركه للقضاء وهذا عمل سياسي
بامتياز اي انه لا يريد ان يدخل في مساله
يبث فيها القضاء لكن في النهايه يعني
الجميع في امريكا كما قلت يعني متاهب
للقفز على الاخر لان المساله اصبحت حديه
جدا لدرجه انه لابد من حلها بطريقه يتدخل
بها عقلاء وليس فقط من الناحيه القانونيه
وعلى العموم يعني نحن امامنا يبدو فتره
طويله من متابعه هذه القضيه والمزيد من
المفاجات والمواجهات بنشكرك كان معنا
الباحث في العلاقات الدوليه الدكتور احمد
عجاج شكرا لك
ومشاهدينا احنا وصلنا لختام حلقه اليوم
اللي خصصناها لمستجدات
استدعاء ترامب
للمحكمه في امان الله مشاهدينا
[موسيقى]